[musique]
Oh oh oh oh oh oh
Suppression de près de 19 % du pain des parents et suppression du pain Kanghyuk contenant du corona.
Quelles sont les mesures ?
Je peux dire que je suis prêt.
[musique]
Ugh euh euh euh
Il n'y en avait pas, ils l'ont vérifié dès leur arrivée pour sentir ce qu'ils allaient faire.
Il a été fait pour entrer
Lors de la vérification, j'ai vérifié l'état de l'intérieur et de l'extérieur et il semblait que la route était la même et que les autres personnes étaient les mêmes.
Que dois-je dire?C’est ainsi que je suis entré dans le cours.
Vous pouvez être rassuré, mais ça
[musique]
nous
un
eww
Qu’est-ce qu’un abri intelligent de type Seongdong ?
Avec ce climat anormal et des canicules de plus en plus sévères,
Protège les riverains des poussières fines et des divers polluants générés sur les routes.
Comment utiliser les transports de Perth et Gaesu de manière plus pratique et plus intelligente
Nous avons introduit
ou euh
Ugh euh euh euh